October 17th meeting of the HB 609
subcommittee I'm representative Michael
Vose chair of this
subcommittee and we have with us today
representative Corman representative
McGee and representative Harrington
representative Kaplan will not be able
to attend so before we get started with
our actual business I'd ask you all to
stand and join me in reciting the pledge
IED Al to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
okay once again thank you for being here
today this is the second meeting of the
HB 9 subcommittee our first meeting was
on October the 3 and at that meeting we
decided to we reviewed a uh some draft
legislation that we would consider for
an amendment for HB
609 and we went over that draft
legislation and came up with some
changes that we thought needed to be
made one of those changes was to the
role of the site evaluation committee
administrator the other was to Define
what substantial change
means and the third definite that we
wanted to add to this potential
amendment was some language to describe
how a special track or a fast track for
um energy projects that are going to be
built on an existing site how that would
work and then the other possibility that
we considered was to move forward with a
change in the makeup of the site
evaluation committee reducing the
current number of members from nine to a
future number of five and that uh number
of five would be described as the three
members of the Pu the commissioner of
the Department of Environmental Services
and a public member and at the time we
discussed the possibility that that
public member would be an attorney
with expertise in land use
planning and after discussing that idea
with uh Tom getts who has been a
consultant for us on this project and
some other
folks it became obvious that restricting
it to an attorney land use planning
expertise would narrow the field to such
a degree that we might have trouble
filling that
role
so we've had a redraft of
the proposed
amendment and there are copies up here a
few extra copies if anybody out there
would like to have a look at what we're
going to be working from here today and
what we decided to go
with was the existing statutory
description of public
members such public members and I'm
going to read from the statute that's
RSA 162 H colon
4-b number one such public members shall
be residents of the State of New
Hampshire with expertise or experience
in one or more of the following areas
public deliberative or adjudicative
proceedings business management
Environmental Protection natural
resource protection energy facility
design construction operation or
management community and Regional
planning or Economic Development
municipal or County government or the
governing of unincorporated
places that I believe will provide a
adequate number of potential candidates
so that we can find a public member
and an alternate public member that
would be well qualified to participate
in the SEC
process
so that's the first change that the
proposed uh legislation that I the draft
legislation that each member of the
subcommittee has before you here that's
the first change that
um that this draft reflects now
representative Corman had a
suggestion to add some language to one
public member specifying that it'd be
chosen by the governor and Council but
that language is also part of
H4
DB where it says the governor with the
consent of the council shall appoint one
public member and an alternate public
member so that language is there um I
think we we potentially could ad
language that says um one public member
as specified in RSA 162
h-4 col
b or whatever the exact H col
4-b the exact
um uh reference
there there is one other change in that
section and that is that three members
of the committee shall constitute a
quorum for the purpose of conducting the
committee's business except that the
three Public Utilities Commissioners
alone shall not constitute a quum I
think that was language that we agreed
was important to add to our at our last
meeting the next section that I think
needs review is Section
Five which says that the senior serving
attorney member of the Public Utilities
Commission Shall Serve as the
chairperson and Ching chief executive of
the committee and May and then it goes
on to describe exactly what the the
chairperson can and cannot do or should
be responsible for and I understand from
talking to several people about this
that this could be
controversial so I've asked the Public
Utilities Commission to come here this
morning to talk to us about this and we
have a representative the of the Pu Mr
Alex spidel or is it sidel spel
spidel could you uh come up to the
microphone here and let us know what the
commission thinks of the idea of making
the senior attorney on the commission be
the chairperson of the
SEC good morning members of of the
subcommittee um representative o good to
see you again representative
Harrington um representative Harrington
and I worked together at the commission
years ago and I would like to offer in
the first instance that the commission
would abide by any determinations made
by the general court as part of this
bill or any enactment of this bill but I
can offer some historical perspective
and experience on how
administratively things work at the
Commission in conjunction with the site
evaluation
committee so around 2015 it was the year
2015 I was appointed by chairman Martin
honigberg of the Public Utilities
Commission to serve as his design on a
subcommittee relating to the
C3 uh upgrade in the town of Newington
and that process proceeded for about 90
days it was a very successful process in
so far as the party including Citizen
interveners and various municipalities
on the Sea Coast and their fire
departments and the applicant were able
to negotiate and Advocates were able to
negotiate a settlement resolving all
issues and essentially recommending that
the subcommittee approve an exemption
request from full sight evaluation
committee review and as the presiding
officer together with my colleagues on
the subcommittee we approve that request
through the settled
process throughout this process reported
to Chairman Martin honberg who was the
chairman of the Public Utilities
Commission and also chairman of the site
evaluation committee and in the view of
the commission it would be optimal to
maintain a clear designation of
authority of lines of authority and
lines of personnel um I would say
responsibility and reporting to the
chair Anderson of the Public Utilities
Commission whether they are an attorney
or not because uh in any agency it's
important to maintain clear lines of
responsibility and Reporting and the
chairperson of the Public Utilities
Commission is really the ideal Hub of
the
puc and so we have had non-attorney
chairpersons we have one right now who's
an engineer and I think to um I think
the phrase that fits would be to
privilege experience in an attorney over
experience in an engineer or a scientist
or an economic person would be a mistake
because I think any chair person that
has been put in that position of
authority by the governor and the
executive councel is usually Stellar
professional who's capable of managing
the SEC process and the Pu process so I
just recommend and advise that we stick
with the concept of the governing
Authority within the PC and the p 's
operations within the site evaluation
committee to be maintained within the
person of the chairperson thank
you thank you so did I understand you to
say that if the Pu chair and the secc
chair were different people that it
would create problems with regard
to reporting and other administrative
activity within the two
groups I would say that if the general
court wanted to make the chairman of the
Public Utilities
Commission uh the
primary responsible person from the
Public Utilities Commission at the SEC
and then have a separate attorney
design out there being the chairperson
that could cause some problems because
you may have designes and folks on the
subcommittees that are being selected by
the chairman of the Public Utilities
Commission to work on sub subcommittee
work and to do other such activities um
not necessarily having clear lines of
Direction and so far as you may have two
Personnel at the P assuming that they
are two Commissioners providing uh
concurrent advice regarding what the
Personnel should be up to and so I did
report to Chairman honigberg when I was
at the Pu as a site evaluation committee
design I would check in with him to make
sure that our overall operational
Direction was satisfactory he did not
interfere in day-to-day operations or
decision- making but I would double
check to make sure that our general
thrust of Direction was in the right
direction so I just offer that thank
you okay uh representative m McGee has a
question but before we get to that I
just want one more
clarification the draft from which we
are working which reduces the number of
SEC members from 9 to
five in addition to making this suggest
change that we're discussing right now
it also eliminates subcommittees it
repeals the part of part of Statute that
creates or allows for the use of
subcommittees so that all SEC business
would
become
uh full SEC business there would be no
more
subcommittees so the piece the the
clarification I need here is that if
there were no subcommittees would there
still be some kind of a reporting
conflict
potentially between the Pu
chair and a different person acting as
the SEC chair namely the attorney
serving on the
Pu one question I would have in terms of
how you all imagine this would operate
is would there be any need for
supporting pu Personnel to offer
analytical services to the site
evaluation committee is there an
expectation that the site evaluation
Committee in its new form would leverage
and utilize the anical analytical
resources of the senior advisers and
Attorneys at the
Pu I think the answer to that is
yes so in that instance or I would
reiterate that it would be best to have
those people reporting to and responding
to the directives of the chairman of the
Public Utilities
Commission okay representative McGee has
a question thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um so when
you explained that you were a design
that was allowed to run a committee or
an SEC uh docket or process uh you said
that you reported directly back to the
chairman of the
Pu Mr honberg
hburg is that correct yes Martin
honigberg he's now correct at the
current time um a Justice of the
superior court I I remember him I when
he was at at the SEC um so I guess what
I'm confused about is if if the
amendment to this bill moves forward
naming uh the attorney currently serving
on the puc as the person who would head
up the adjudicative proceedings for the
SEC wouldn't that person still have the
same communication vehicle with the
chair that you had when you ran the
process that you said was so successful
well I don't want to necessarily assume
um Madame representative that I would
know all the permutations of how this
would play out in real time but I would
offer this that there could be a
circumstance
where the most senior attorney on the
commission is not necessarily the
chairperson so you know that kind of
creates an inherent tension
because especially in the current format
of the commission you really do directly
uh respond and are on a Personnel level
responsible to the chairperson of the
commission so it's that classic example
of what happens when you have two
captains of the ship where do you go as
a subordinate employee I'm just speaking
for myself kind of my own sense of how
this would play out because I'm always
very responsive to what my uh
supervising people are interested in my
advice for but also to whatever they
would like me to um do and where they
would like to guide me I don't want to
necessarily find myself as a senior
adviser in a position of having to um
deal with contradictory guidance so I I
would say that again I would reiterate
that to have that setup could create
problems on a Personnel basis uh at the
Public Utilities Commission because you
would have a junior commissioner who is
not a chairperson
um operating in this framework you have
subordinate employees of which there are
not very many in the commission having
to engage in site evaluation committee
business and potentially receiving
contradictory direction from two
different people it's just the nature of
things and I would further add that the
commission by Design is a bipartisan
structure so there's often um you you
have essentially a
multiple potential for confusion or lack
of clarity on how things are approached
may I follow
up thank you um okay so I I understand
what you're what you're
saying um
now Martin hburg was an attorney and I
think one of the objectives that we had
in in requesting that the attorney
representative on the Pu be the person
who heads up the SEC is because we
thought there was a value in having
someone with direct adjudicative
experience in that role um my
understanding of the appointment of the
current chair of the Pu is that his
background he had no background in in
energy and no background um that would
be relevant to the role that that he's
currently presiding in his chair uh
certainly for site evaluation and so I'm
not trying to diminish
um you know his contribution and his
ability and his his business background
and all that but I um I think the
concern is that we not give all of the
responsibility to just the person who
currently resides in that chairship um
there's no reason why someone junior or
otherwise who serves as a pu
commissioner couldn't take on those
responsibilities especially if they have
again the adjudicative U background and
also background in New Hampshire's
energy uh that the other two
Commissioners
possess so it's just it's my perspective
that we've had some issues with with
legislative directives and the way
they've been carried out under the
interpretations of a person who doesn't
really have a lot of experience and
energy and I have to bring that up in
the hearing here because we've we've
already had
to uh rework or undo or go back and try
and address issues that have come up
before the Pu uh in its current
formation because it was not um
interpreted in the way that it was
intended so so do you have a question
for yeah I mean that's what I'm saying
I'm saying uh identifying having a
judicative experience directly as being
the chair for the SEC which is a
separate process uh it's not part of the
Pu it's just that the Pu has always been
part of you know has always participated
in that board in that committee um I I
guess what I'm asking is what relevant
experience you think the current chair
brings to the SEC
process um that would make it important
for him to be in charge of both I don't
think you need to answer that question I
I think that question is kind of
irrelevant to the subject we're
discussing here we're trying to come up
with a process that will
work uh going
forward and so we don't need to to
discuss the personalities or the the
qualifications of the current employees
of the of the commission or the SEC what
we're trying to do here is create a
process that will allow whoever is
serving and whoever is appointed
remembering that these appointment are
typically made by the governor right and
Council and I think I guess my point is
to go back to the the point that is
being presented to us is that
administratively it would be messy if
the head of the SEC is not the same as
the head of the Pu and my question is
really give us some details of that
because I I I just think you gave us an
example where you headed up an SEC
proceeding and reported back to the
chair of the people you see and didn't
run into any problems so uh I just don't
see how the configuration that we've
provided here would not
work yes if you have any details that
yes or examples of how such an
arrangement could be difficult we'd love
to hear those so I would just like to
reiterate that especially in the current
structure because in the old puc that
was combined with the department of
energy was a bigger
agency um essentially had all the
Personnel under the rubric of the Public
Utilities Commission and you had
intermediary management personnel with
titles such as executive director and
general counsel and so forth um but here
it's a very small flat agency so I
report directly to the
chairman uh Mr uh Dan goldner so it's a
very direct connection and I think the
answer that was provided by
representative Vose was well we're going
to expect the senior advisers at the
Public Utilities Commission you know we
have a lot of expertise in this area um
a lot of experience we're going to be
expected to help out the state through
the site evaluation committee through
the analytical process and the legal
analysis process and the leg work
process of preparing the orders and so
forth so if you
have if you're putting those employees
in a position where you're report
according to a junior commissioner
instead of your chairperson and I'm
talking about the future I think
representative V was exactly on target
with that I'm talking about 20 years in
the future and it's not necessarily
about me personally it's about the
future subordinate employees of the
commission as it's currently constituted
they could be put in an uncomfortable or
confusing situation and regarding the
qualifications of the current chairman
or someone like that in the future um he
is a business exec ative of 35 years
experience in the semiconductor industry
in the defense industry uh he's a very
highly educated electrical engineer he
has a lot of insight on how
international business works and how
business at large works so there are
skill sets beyond the attorney skill set
that can offer a lot to the site
evaluation Committee in future for
instance we could have a research
scientist a physicist or someone like
that who would serve as chairperson of
the SEC and they wouldn't necessarily be
the attorney but as
a as a captain of the ship as a leader
of the agency they could provide a lot
of assistance to the SEC effort and
reassure their subordinate employees
that when they're helping out on that
they're getting clear Direction on what
to do so I would encourage consideration
of that point um um representative Vose
do you think uh you I've answered all
your questions I think you have thank
you now there may be other questions
from other members here so
representative Harrington for example
has a question thank you thank you for
taking my question it's nice to see you
again too same here thank you it's been
a long time um I I think on what I'm
trying to see here is that you're
talking about the when you go down the
middle of the page five there it says
senior serving attorney member of the
Public Utilities Commission Shall Serve
as
chairperson and as chief executive of
the
committee but then the committee is is
attached to the Department of energy
administratively is that where the
confusion part is coming from and also
so followup to that maybe it's in here
someplace that I'm missing it but I
don't see anybody being named chair of
the site evaluation committee there's
just the members are listed but no one
is listed as chair so if that was
defined as let's just say for example
the the chair of the Pu would that make
this more operable for you in this way
or is the fact that it's
administratively assigned to the
Department of energy causing the
confusion if it is I missed it can you
tell me where it
is you just
read the senior serving member of the
public utilities the senior serving
member of the Public Utilities
Commission shall Ser oh okay I I thought
that minute I thought I I read that as a
staff attorney not the fact that one of
the Commissioners is an attorney that's
what you're referring to okay all right
so that's what so what we're discing so
forget about that then the confusion
factor is that you have
people that is it attached to the
Department of energy but your the
whatever
this you have people working for the
commission at the same time is that
where the confusions com from um I don't
think so representative Harrington I I
just read the language a few moments ago
was presented to me just a few moments
ago to to the room so to speak and uh I
will offer this that the same rubric of
being attached to the administratively
attached to the Department of energy
pertains to the Public Utilities
Commission itself under sb2 so that
means the mechanics of for example we
have Personnel over in the department of
energy that help us out with our
business office needs so for instance
things such as reimbursement of travel
expenses and uh Human Resources type
things such as health insurance and
things like that so I think that's what
that refers to and perhaps the new
Personnel um the administrator coming
into the P Mothership so to speak also
being able to make use of the
administrative attachment to the
Department of energy the department of
energy also does more mundane things for
us such as I believe office supplies
acquisition of some of that material and
things of that nature okay all right and
just one followup I think you know I I
think it' be easy to make the mistake
that I just made because when you refer
to a member of the Public Utilities
Commission that can always be looked at
as anybody that works for the commission
not just Commissioners normally when we
refer to Commissioners we we spell it
out so it would have to be something
like the senior the commissioner who's
the senior serving attorney of the
Public Utilities Commission so it's
clear that we're talking about a
commissioner here and not I read it as
the senior attorney that worked for the
commission not being a commissioner so I
think that would help clarify it thank
you that's a good clarification thank
you representative Corman do you have a
question yes thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question uh and
actually this is probably more of a
question for the chair but uh you
referred to
um uh the possibility of of designes of
the uh pu serving on the site evaluation
commission as I think I heard you say
that well that was in the past that was
in 2015 when we had the subcommittee
structure and I believe we still have it
in theory now but in you it appears that
in the latest you know this subcommittee
question has gone through some to and
fro over the last uh year or so and it
seems that now you're toggling into the
no category on the subcommittee question
right right so I just want to verify uh
I guess with with the chair uh as I read
the current draft it doesn't even admit
for designes of the Pu Commissioners it
would just be the three pu Commissioners
yes correct okay thank you um I do have
a separate well a comment more than a
question um I'm just thinking about this
this issue of let's say authority of of
a subordinate commissioner serving as
chair of the
SEC when when it's not necess yes
serving as chair of the SEC and not
necessarily the puc chair so that you
sort of have an inversion there
um it's not directly relevant but I just
want to point out I I I chaired
departments uh at Dartmouth for 10 years
and we would often have committees
within the Departments and I we'd have a
chair of the committee who wasn't me as
as department chair and I would serve on
the committee and you know I can just
say there there was never an issue was
clear what the lines of authority were
within that Committee of the department
and it was clear what the lines of
authority were within the department as
a whole so I think this can be worked
out and you know I just don't really see
a huge problem
here all right well this seems to be an
issue that needs further discussion so I
want to thank you Mr spidel for being
here and giving giving us your
perspective thank you Mr chairman and
I'd like to hear maybe from the
Department of energy uh Mr Elms and Mr
shulock if you could give us your
perspective on this question of whether
having the senior serving attorney
member of the Public Utilities
Commission or serve as the
chairperson and chief chief executive of
the
SEC is a conflict a good idea a bad idea
what do you think sure uh for the record
Chris Elms Deputy Commissioner of the
New Hampshire Department of energy and
I'm joined by David shulock our general
counsel um I'd like to preface my
comments by saying that I think Carlton
Simpson is a fabulous job uh in his
current role I think he'd be a fabulous
chairman of any committee or
commissioner whatever you put him in
charge of but I personally and and again
doe we're not a part of this this is
just our perspective as fellow state
agencies and and with some so certainly
experience uh in this realm when when it
was at when we were the Pu um we would
be opposed to this provision I think you
know when we saw the language we were a
little bit you know kind of questioning
what is the problem that we're here to
solve you know I I I'm sure you all have
the same experience that I have which is
experience with chairman of various
committees commissions whatever who
aren't attorneys who do an excellent job
and I'm sure we've all dealt with
attorneys who and you know no all due
respect to the attorneys in the room
including the one to my right but who
can get bogged down in minutia or
whatever it might be who might not be
the most effective um in an adjudicative
session um setting uh and and frankly I
don't think an attorney Alone um has
necessarily A judicative experience
Beyond um you know someone else I think
uh you
know what I've heard here here is that
part of what we're looking at in terms
of making this change is uh in part due
to ideological misalignment with the
current chairman of the Public Utilities
Commission um I don't know of any
problems that the SEC has had in terms
of their fulfilling their adjudicative
responsibilities uh there was an example
used that the legislature has had to
come in and fix things uh the one
example I can think of is obviously
House Bill 549 which our agency was uh
you know involved in the in the draft
and passage of with the legislature
including folks in the room uh I I would
point out that the decision that that
was in response to was made under uh a
chairman who was an attorney and no
longer works at the commission uh so I I
don't see how that would be a relevant
example in this case of solving um you
know a problem with an attorney not
doing a great job um you know the way we
see it is that the individual matters
and that you know the way it's been set
up with the Pu and the SEC has been
successful the venue for issues related
to Personnel uh would probably be more
appropriate for the governor and Council
and not uh legislation um obviously the
legislature has the prerogative to do
what you'd
like but I think you might want to ask
yourself whether or not legislating on
the basis of an
individual um who has a term and you
know there is a process to to go through
that and that is uh the governor and
councel uh David do you have anything
that you want to add to that
no nothing to add representative
Harrington has a question thank you and
thank you for taking my question just as
a based on your experience I'm wondering
if this creates a bit of confusion as
well we have the uh what we now know is
the commission the Pu commissioner who's
the senior serving attorney Shall Serve
as is the chief executive officer of the
committee um and list all the things he
does but then we talk about the
administrator and the administrator she
be hired by and under the supervision of
the chairperson of the Public Utilities
Commission who in many cases might not
be the senior attorney and he duties as
assigned and extent blah blah blah blah
so you have administrator who reports to
the chair of the Pu and then you have an
SEC who was chaired by someone other
than the chair of the Pu does that build
in confusion in your mind yeah and and I
would say that it's you know as as
attorney spidel alluded to nothing is
insurmountable and if the general court
wants to go in that direction I'm sure
they will figure it out um but it does
introduce a level of structural
awkwardness that is is just going to
make the process less efficient and it's
going to make the process a little more
difficult to achieve and could lead to a
situation where folks are not as able to
as effectively do their jobs in either
the Pu or the the SEC and if you know
for us as we see it uh is the juice
worth the squeeze right is the problem
that you're solving going to be balanced
out by the difficulties you're
introducing I I would say no but
obviously that is the general Court's
prerogative anything to add Mr
shulok um I I think I would add that it
it is going to be very confusing for
employees at the Pu to understand which
Master they should listen to um and the
the system that you're setting up
depends upon those two masters getting
along communicating well with one
another and agreeing on how um the pu's
assets um Personnel assets will will be
utilized right and it's wonderful when
those three Commissioners get along but
I can tell you they don't always I have
witnessed it it is paralyzing and you
could paralyze two agencies um by having
disagreement among the two chiefs so
it's really something I would recommend
against as a um
open so to follow up on representative
Harrington's question if the puc
commissioner is responsible
for supervising the
employee who is
occasionally design designated to be the
SEC
administrator could
he cause problems by not allowing that
person
to serve an adequate amount of time to
serve the the position that he's being
asked to serve as SEC administrator I I
do think that's what you're setting up
so you know
part of the the thinking of this is you
bring the administrator inside so that
um there is no downtime for that
employee right um that their extra time
is covered by work at the Pu and paid
for by the assessment right so uh so
that there's a free flow of money that's
the Pu
Chairman's prerogative right
so they're going to be a that chair
person is going to be assigning work to
be done at the Pu right and could just
load it up
right thank you the SEC chair could do
the same right and then you're just you
know if they're if you assume that
they're going to get along and they're
going to communicate and you know there
are enough hours to go around
everything's wonderful but TR trust me
they don't
always okay representative Harrington as
I would agree with that last statement
been there and lived it um I think we're
kind of chasing a red herring here I
mean we somehow we're coming with the
assumption that the chair of the Pu is
not qualified to run to be chair of the
site evaluation committee yet he's been
appointed chair of the Pu which is going
to be meeting on a much more regular
basis having a lot more money involved
in it and they've been appointed by the
governor confirmed by the executive
counsel as being able to fulfill the
duties of the chair of the Pu so to say
that somehow because he's not a lawyer
if that's the case he's not allowed to
be able to fulfill the duties of the
fite evaluation committee I think he's a
red hering we're chasing we just should
there's no need for this put one person
in charge and if that person happens to
be a lawyer great if he's not he's got
great legal staff that he can contact I
just think this is a problem that
doesn't exist that we're trying to
solve okay do either of you have a
question for these
gentlemen
all right thank you we appreciate you
being here to answer our questions and I
reserve the right to call you back as we
go through other parts of this
legislation to
clarify other aspects of the amendment
we're trying to draft
here so section five under um H3 seems
to be problematic and we'll have to have
a further discussion about what to do
with that but before we do that let's
move on and talk about some of the other
changes that this draft
makes um so that we can decide whether
or not certain language stays or certain
language
goes section six which uh is the very
next section of H3 lets the commissioner
of the Department of Environmental
Services designate other
people to serve in his stead on a
specific SEC proceeding that person
could be an employee from the Department
of Transportation the Department of
Natural and cultural resources the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs etc
etc that is a change from
existing statute it would be necess
necessitated by the reduction of
an SEC of nine members down to five
members do you see that as as being
useful or do we need to ask questions
about
that representative
Corman yeah um I have no objection to
that my only concern is that uh I found
the language potentially ambiguous as to
whether the design would be uh in
addition to the dees commissioner or in
in instead of the the dees commissioner
and i' I'd like the wording to make it
clear that we're talking about somebody
who would be substituting for the dees
commissioner okay that's that's a good
point uh I I think the intent of
the paragraph is to allow the dees
commissioner to
substitute someone else for himself but
we we will get clarification on
that representative Harrington yeah just
to follow up on that same paragraph I
think that's a good point I had the same
question it wasn't clear if it was in
addition to but I think it the intent is
here in place of um this seems to give
the uh unilateral authority to the
commissioner of Dees to decide I'm out
but the Department of Natural Resources
and natural and cultural resources is in
um of course they'd have to agree to do
it but but um I'm just wondering if we
would want to have the commission make
that that the SEC make that decision
that a recommendation by the department
of environmental resources commissioner
saying in this particular case I think
the Department of Transportation would
be better represented but be more more
helpful than um the uh Dees on the
commission so I'm recommending to the
commission to the SEC that they replace
me with them it just seems to make a
little bit more sense that we have since
we are talking about a major change here
because it's not saying that the dees
commissioner if they're going to just
say which happens many times on the side
of valuation committee I simply can't
make this as commissioner so I'm going
to appoint my senior staff member in Li
of me but he's still a department member
who reports to me uh this says I'm going
to repoint someone from a totally
different oops totally different
department which I have no authority
over and they're going to come in and
have now have a vote and I just think
that should be subject to review of the
commission as a whole of this SEC as a
whole so if we added language to the end
of that paragraph that said subject to
approval of the full committee yeah
would that address your
issues okay thank you further comment on
this
section okay next is the uh 162 H3 D
administrator and other committee
support now this is language that
changes the current SEC administrator
from a full-time employee of the
SEC even though he's paid for by the
Public Utilities Commission to a
full-time employee of the Public
Utilities Commission who can float
between duties at the Pu and the
secc
and this is one of the I think more
important changes that we can make to
streamline the operation of the
SEC I think we should go forward with
this uh with this change unless there is
any objection or I heard this morning
was
that please turn on your mic thank you
Mr chairman um yeah what what what we
heard just briefly this morning was that
it might be problematic if the schedule
of that administrator is loaded up by
the Pu right if they find a bunch of
work for them then they may not may not
have time to do the SEC work so we
probably do need to legislatively figure
out what we can put in here to ensure
that when there's an
SEC project that that administrator is
allowed to devote their time you know
sufficient time to that project because
otherwise it will not be properly
supported any ideas any ideas follow on
that I think if we um if if we address
the issue that I brought up earlier and
let's just say we go with the
chairperson of the Pu being the head of
the SEC and the Pu that will correct
that problem because one person is not
going to say you got to work 35 hours a
week on this project for the Pu but I'm
also telling you to work 35 hours a week
for this project on the SEC because
making a singular person have the
authority for both will eliminate the
problem it's a legitimate concern the
way it's written but I think that'll get
that'll eliminate it yeah that's a good
point
um having the Pu commissioner be the
chair of the would eliminate that
problem
agreed representative Corman thank you
um might it be worth actually including
in the statute language saying that the
administrator uh shall prioritize work
for the SEC
okay
that language seems reasonable at first
blush but if the Pu commissioner is the
one who's supervising this
employee then the employee himself can't
prioritize right his work on the SEC it
would have to be the
commissioner himself who prioritized
this person's work on the SEC
I I would I think what I'm hearing from
representative Corman is the idea that
the administrator who is currently an
SEC resource and is now being asked to
take on puc work in the time that he's
idle that there has to be some language
in here that basically states that his
role is that support role and that that
should take priority maybe he can't make
it a priority but we should maybe state
that his his priority job is support of
the SEC and his additional time will be
taken up with pu duties uh as he is
available right so so so
something um something that states that
SEC comes first in terms of why he was
hired and what his job is right and that
was my intent thank you so the
the
the position of
administrator shall
be but says that the position may be
filled by an independent contractor as
it's currently worded because it because
it won't necessarily always be the same
person as we were discussing in the
other sections but this definition goes
on to the second page and it basically
says uh the chair um reports is under
the supervision of the chairperson of
the Public Utilities Commission shall
perform duties for the Public Utilities
Commission and the site evaluation
committee as directed by the chairperson
of the Pu so maybe it should be site
evaluation committee first and
um I think there should be a statement
that this person is a resource to the
site evaluation committee first I don't
know how we're going to word it
but okay so change the priority to make
SEC first
priority and then other pu
duties and work on other yeah secondary
um secondary to sec
responsibilities just another comment on
that section well going along with the
having the two separate people be in
charge because we've also say here now
any person hired by the administrator
shall be approved by the chairperson of
the Public Utilities Commission so as
written the chair of the site evaluation
committee would not approve the hiring
of outside contractors for the site
evaluation committee but the chair of
the Pu would so I think it's that's
another example why we have to make
those one and the
same okay good
point any other problems with the
language in this section yes
representative Corman yes I think I
noted this uh in email I sent around to
the subcommittee really minor thing the
stricken material at the end of this
section actually is in is stricken but
from the wrong section it should be from
uh H3 not
h3a where is that so the the the
stricken material that starts in the
case of a public member yeah the
procedure outlined in RSA Etc that here
it appears at the end of section
h3a but in current statute it's actually
at the end of section H3
oh and it says H4
B yeah but the actual text that's
stricken if you look at the current
statute it's not at the end of h3a it's
at the end of H3 I'm I'm just saying
that this is this needs to be moved uh
it's going to be stricken but it needs
to be moved to the correct place where
it's going to be stricken which is at
the end of
H3 I made a note of that so talk the
training aspect yeah
all
right the next
section can I ask a question on that oh
yes of course thanks um I was looking at
that earlier and my question is is there
a point to people having training in
terms of what they're doing on the site
evaluation committee that we're saying
they don't need any training they're
just going to make make decisions on I
mean I I think the decisions are
supposed to be objectively made based on
the findings of what's presented to the
committee but is there any benefit to
the training that we're
eliminating the training was added to
statute and I remember this well because
I sponsored the amendment that added
that section to the
statute was aimed primarily at the
public
members and was
also aimed at dealing with the churn
where there were there was an on some
occasions as many as 40 different people
serving on the site evaluation committee
all with different training and
expertise and so this this part of the
statute was added when when we had that
chur in situation the changes that we're
seeking to make here would eliminate
that churn and therefore potentially
eliminate the need for the training
thank
you okay next is um
this amendment would
um would keep hb4 the public members
section whereas it would have been
repealed under the previous version we
did skip the hb4a subcommittee repeal
discuss that coming out FAS that's next
what's that that's next oh okay I
thought you were skipping on to public
that's next what do you mean that's next
oh he's talking about the sub gone away
just the subcommittee Sor the
subcommittees were repealed because we
don't have subcommittees anymore so that
section h4a is no longer okay exist
right
okay so that might necessitate a change
in numbering
yeah or we'll let 's figure that out
they're the experts on that so
so then the language on public members
is basically there to
clarify when a public member has to
recuse himself or has to be absent
Etc that the alternate member would
would take his
place on any proceeding that was active
at the
time and um there's also some language
here about how they get
comp compensated for
their for their
service representative Corman thank you
um so when I looked at the uh the list
of areas that we are looking for
expertise from the public
member it's a pretty long list and it
looks like at least the first item or
two are Maybe duplic duplicative of what
we already have on the SEC especially
public deliberative or adjudicative
proceedings we already have the Pu
Commissioners they they have experience
in that area um i' I'd really rather see
really the Environmental Protection
natural resource protection pretty much
everything starting from Environmental
Protection I think those are the areas
of expertise that would be not
represented on the SEC without a public
member
um I'm not sure on Miss business
management I'm lukewarm on that but I I
feel like we could remove public
deliberative or adjudicative proceedings
because we already have that and it's
more important to get expertise in the
other areas in that list
yeah I wouldn't object to that that's
sounds reasonable Mr I would go along
with getting R of the public defend uh
adjudicative proceeding but business
management is actually part of the
evaluation they have to one of the part
of the evaluation is can the company
build the project and so I think
business management should
stay okay that makes sense
too any other further discussion of
section H4
DB all right moving to section H callon
5 prohibitions and
restrictions the significant change here
is the last four lines which defines
what a substantial change or addition
means and the language chosen for this
definition is a greater than onethird
increase in the capital investment
capacity footprint or height of an
existing energy
facility or a change in the energy
source for an electric Generating
Station or other reuse of a
site as an reuse of a site as an energy
facility now in a separate document that
I handed out to
everyone there is a proposal for
creating an advanced track or a
condensed track a fast
track that would allow changes to an
existing site to be made more
expeditiously in 180 days as opposed to
days and the specifics of the process
that we're
envisioned or are envisioned are set out
here and the question then becomes do we
need all of this information in an
append in an amendment in statutory
language or is this something that the
SEC might work out in
rules which would indicate that maybe
the statutes should say uh the
commission will develop rules to handle
FastTrack changes to existing facilities
representative Harrington yeah yeah
having lived through a very very lengthy
discussion on what a substantial
increase is and this is sort of the same
thing this idea what constitutes a fast
trck I would think the leg legisl should
give guidance on this and not leave it
uh just uh figure it out yourself SEC
and go write some rules because that
could come out like I say I have a bill
out there now where we the legislature
passed a section of this bill which
directly and only applies to win
facilities but when the SEC wrote their
rules they applied all those new
restrictions to every type of facility
even though it was never in the law so I
don't want to give the uh rulemaking
that much leeway I think we need to
supply some type of guidance
okay given that reality I think that
this outline of a process for doing a
FastTrack which is fully two pages
long may be beyond our capability to
produce an amendment for this this year
and might require the submission of a a
new bill in order to make this happen Mr
chairman do we have a v vehicle that we
could use for updates in the coming
year do you know I don't I haven't
looked at the LSR list I don't know if
there are any SEC bills on that list or
not however the Senate could submit a
bill to do this fast track uh I don't
think that maybe this
amendment is the place to do
this representative Harrington what do
you think of the definition of
substantial change or addition um I
think it's well worked out with I have
one question on it though and then this
is a u just an aging factor I guess if
you want to substantial change talks
about greater than onethird increase in
the in capital investment well let's say
the the uh facility is 30 years old and
it was built for $100 million and now
you want to put in some change that's
going to cost 80 Mill million so that
would not cover a sub be it would be
considered a substantial change but if
you would have build the original
facility today it would cost $800
million so using that logic it wasn't a
substantial change so somehow we're
going to have to make sure that the
capital investment as adjusted for
inflation or something because otherwise
uh you're going to get an awful lot of
things that because things have just
gotten so expensive over the last 20 30
years that you would be would everyone
would look at as being that's not
substantial change but it's going to be
more than onethird of the original
capital costs so you can have adjusted
for inflation or something good point
representative Corman thank you uh so I
I actually had a similar thought to
representative Harrington's thought um
but well we we've agreed in the past on
on rare occasion um but I also was
thinking uh typically the capital
investment isn't always just like once
at the beginning it's it's you know over
a period of time uh I'm just thinking
how difficult that would be to actually
account for with you know with the
discount rate and all that um I had one
other comment which is when we talk
about a onethird increase in say
capacity or or yeah name let's say name
plate
capacity for a large plant a onethird
increase is a really big increase um for
a small plant you know it's not that big
a deal but for a large plant a one-third
increase could really be a significant
increase with a significant impact so
I'm not really sure how to go about that
but I feel
like we might want to have some absolute
number a one-third increase or an
increase over a certain capacity a
certain certain amount of
Generation Um and either one would would
trigger um well yeah representative
McGee My thought might be that the
trigger would be if the change at the
plant were to increase beyond the name
plate capacity by a quarter or more um
well it could be a third or it could be
30% but
um to representative corman's point in
some cases that's a significant
increase
well to use his example let's say it was
a 30 megawatt solar facility a onethird
increase would be 10 y but let's say
we're talking about a 700 megawatt gas
plant a onethird increase would be much
larger than 10 right
so I just comment on this I I would to
agree because
um if you are talking about increasing
uh by say over 100 megaw I mean we
already have a provision that says
anything over 30 megawatts new has to go
to the site evaluation committee so I
would think that that's uh that's a see
we've agreed again um but today we got
to write this one down um that that
that's a good point because you if
you're talking about putting in you know
if you had that 700 or 900 megawatt gas
plant and you increased it by 250 megaw
that that's a substantial change I I
think and you're talking about you know
increasing uh pipeline boiler emissions
and stuff like that so some cap I don't
know what a logical number would be but
it's going to be somewhat
arbitrary 100 megawatts not to exceed
100 megawatts or not to exceed 50
megawatts or something like that would
be uh would be something that would be
worthwhile putting in because you are
opening up something there for I mean
let's just say for example CBR decided I
don't see how they would do this but
this decided they wanted to increase by
uh they could increase uh you know 400
megaw and uh it would involve new
transmission lines and new emissions
maybe some new cooling systems or
whatever but that's a massive amount of
change and this is what this committee
is supposed to look at so I'd have to
set some cap now what would be rational
on that that's one of the things I'd
like some input from some of the people
in the back of the room that may be
contemplating doing something like this
but uh I I think something like 100
megawatts would clearly be something you
wouldn't want to go over
Mr lot do you have a comment on this
question um not specifically on the
point that representative Harrington was
making but just wanted to um also add I
think the issue of the capital
investment related to the increase is is
problematic and confusing uh as
representative Corman and Harrington
pointed out is that you know the point
of the original project increased by
inflation is it you know the most recent
capital investment I I I'm not sure it
adds value and I think it confuses the
matter um so just wanted to put a fine
point uh I I don't have an opinion on
I'm just seeing this for the first time
uh on the you know increase in
generating capacity but the I think the
capital investment language is
is probably
atic okay thank you Mr manahan do you
have uh some comments to make about this
question I noticed that the document
called SEC reform condensed tract for
changes to existing facilities does have
criteria um repowering of a facility can
be no larger than existing name plate
capacity a project which is expanded or
added added to an existing facility may
not increase the existing name plate by
more than
50% etc
etc it seems to me that for the purposes
of creating an amendment here this may
be more complicated than what we can
accomplish in the next week and a half
which we have to do in order to get an
amendment ready for an exact session on
November
6th I kind of agree except that if
representative Harrington and Corman are
agreeing on so much today anything's
possible but um yeah I I I should say I
did knowing that we weren't I wasn't
sure how far um House Bill 609 was going
to go I did speak with Senator Waters
during the Senate filing period about
potentially filing a bill and I think he
filed a title uh to address to address
this concept uh which is different a
different animal than the substantial or
sizable addition um section of it um so
um I do
think that should be separate tracks for
that um and then I what I would observe
on the uh sizable addition language that
you have before you today um two weeks
ago when we met I kind of observed that
maybe uh eliminating the
capital um section of it might make
sense for all the reasons that
representative Forman and and hary
observe trying to guess U the way to say
you know is it a fixed dollar amount
that you wouldn't want to put in Bill uh
you know and if a plant was built 30
years ago it's just hard to I think with
the other criteria you could the
commission's capable of figuring out
what in the legislature what sizable
is so um the other issue I you know I'm
seeing again for the first time today
I'm trying to get my arms around is the
uh restriction on the fuel source um
that's included in it uh I I can kind of
appreciate that but I also know what's
in the pipeline uh is probably
facilities that you know big facilities
that want to add storage or big
facilities that want to add solar at a
nons siiz um change it would invite you
wouldn't be able to use that U you know
if if cwork station was going to put in
a you know a 30 megawatt um solar
project uh that's not sizable comp was
it 1300 megaw like yeah so this would be
small piece but because there's a
different fuel type you wouldn't be able
to do it under the uh this the um
sizable addition um uh allowance
so so you're talking about the language
that says or a change in the energy
source yes yeah okay no I understand
there's lots
of stuff buried in there but as we said
before this is not going to be an easy
section to write um and then for example
if a you in order to comply with
reliability expectations if somebody
wanted to add a a fuel storage tank you
know a oil tank at their gas facility um
uh for winter backup it's a different
fuel source and so you know again they
wouldn't be able to do it uh as a um uh
a sizable addition
allowance and it would take them more
than a year to get through the site
evaluation
committee I can see that a change in the
energy source and fuel source might be
different things but you're right it is
problematical language I agree y
representative McGee did you have a
comment I just uh wanted to ask Mr Mahan
if he had heard any Rumblings among the
other people who watch uh about the idea
of putting in language about
non-emitting sources because you seemed
like you were alluding to different
types of fuel that could be added to
different facilities it seems that most
of the uh plants in the area when
they're looking at augmentation or
storage or reliability they are trying
to move toward cleaner sources but um do
you think it's appropriate for us to
consider any of that in terms of the
language here yeah I did talk again this
would probably be more in the potential
Center Waters build than on the sizeable
Edition piece but I did have a good
conversation with folks from
environmental Community um the end of
last week to try to get our arms around
that I'm a little hesitant to do it
because I don't know what is an aobc
digestor uh admit you know does a
biomass plant admit um does um a uh the
production of um uh renewable natural
gas which the legislature endorsed a
couple years ago is that admitting so de
generally speaking I think everything
that's coming down the line is cleaner
um but I'm not sure that um we know with
Precision what it all be that it would
that it's best to put that in the
statute but I I want to work with people
because I'm trying to get everyone to
yes on
this representative Harrington yeah I
realize this is a really tough nut to
crack the example you gave on the dual
fuel is you know it's that's right on
because it's something that I'm not sure
the status of the plants in New
Hampshire if there's if there gas only
that don't have dual fuel capability but
there certainly could be one um on the
other side of it though it's you You'
really got to watch it on this one
because let's just say you had a u i
don't know 100 megawatt Wind Facility
that was existing and they decided in
order to go with their intermittency
that they they decided to put in some
gas turbin and there actually GE
actually does make a turbine gas turbine
wind turbine combination so one runs the
other one doesn't so maybe you decide
let's add the gas I can't see people
saying well we're just adding some more
gas turbines in out there they only run
when the wind's not blowing don't worry
it's not a sizable addition I can see a
lot of people getting very excited about
adding new gas turbin um so I'm just not
I'm not I don't have a solution to it
but I'm just saying eliminating it is
not the answer there going to be some
caveat there I think so and I'm not you
maybe it has maybe it gets to do it has
to do with I was going to say you know
the it won't work to make the current
facility operate more efficiently so
that you don't have to rely on admitting
base load you know intermittent would be
a good good cleaner investment but it's
hard to write that into into uh into 609
maybe that's maybe we address that in
the waters bill
that representative Corbin thank you uh
yeah I mean it seems to me that there
are various permutations that could
happen here right you know what if they
wanted to put wind in uh you know some
some wind turbines in in a solar
installation that was somewhere near
residential you
know my feeling is that we can't really
cover
everything that's possible that could
possibly happen here
so if that's true then how do we air do
we air on the side of more caution or
air on the side of less caution and I
would air on the side of more caution
and I would leave in the change in
energy source recognizing yeah there may
be a time when it probably isn't a big
deal but I'd rather capture the times
when it is a big
deal one other possibility
representative Harrington yeah one other
possibility is I I agree that the uh
it's it could be a big deal I mean if
someone decided to drop an SMR in
someplace that was only 40 megawatts
because it was a you know a 500 megawatt
gas plant for whatever reason uh I'm
sure there'd be people Marching In the
Streets about you're putting a nuclear
plant out there and we don't even get to
talk about it so um but I also think
it's it's going to be very hard not to
crack and since we it sounds like we're
working on the uh changes to existing
facilities which is sort of like a rep
powering and changeing energy energy
source uh or other reuse of the sers and
energy facilities kind of fits into what
we've got over on the repowering portion
maybe we can just leave that stuff off
with the idea we'll pick it up on the
other bill because it seems it seems to
be more in that and probably
deserves uh more attention that we can
give it in one paragraph in this one
yeah maybe that's the way to get it
because if you look at some of the
things that you know weren't you know
like changes at the switch card um or a
new Bank of Transformers or things like
that those are things that got pulled
into the set evaluation committee
because the the amount of money because
of the capital investment so I think
we're already talking about trying to
address that um so I think it's that
type of thing where there has been some
unfortunate lengthy regulatory processes
um we still haven't resolved the issue
of you know backup fuel source and
things like that but maybe right maybe
the other bill is for that yeah I think
if we use that we could still put in the
uh capacity and footprint uh and so
forth take this part out put it with the
other Bill where because we could put
more work into it and more specifics as
to you know it's more of a reuse or
repowering issue rather than a you know
I'm looking like what you do where they
have the problem now with someone comes
in and says well we've got to replace
the switch yard on our whatever plant
because it's 40 years old and it's now
going to cost uh you know we going to
replace part of it and it's going to
cost hundred million do to do it but
we're basically putting the same thing
in we took out out so uh there really
isn't any impact on anybody if anything
is probably been more efficient now than
they were when the old ones were bought
that's the one we want to exempt from
the full side of evaluation committee so
I think that would leaving these words
out would do that as long as we pick
them up on the other side so we do
address them because that is going to be
an issue repowering down the road though
I don't think it's something we have to
address in the next two weeks whatever
we have Mr chairman right I'd only say I
would you know be my commitment to work
with I don't want to wait wait until
April in crossover for uh this
subcommittee or this committee to get it
so I will speak with senat Waters
confirm it was filed and maybe invite
some of you to join as co-sponsors so
you're part of the process as it moves
through the Senate as
well that makes sense so from what I'm
hear I think it's best if we
drop uh all this language from our
Amendment for HB 609 and let that be
covered with additional legislation
going forward talking about I was
suggesting that we drop we we leave the
greater than onethird increase in
capacity footprint or height of an
existing energy facility take out the
rest of the stuff and put it in the
other bill but leave that in so if there
is like like the example that was given
if someone has to go in and replace uh a
bunch of Transformers which you're gone
price has gone out of sight on so it
would be costly but it's basically a one
for one replacement but it's you know
it's going to be something somewhat
different cuz they're going to be they
manufacturing today rather than 40 years
ago so if we left that in that would
still cover that part and then on the
bigger project we would Encompass the
rest of the stuff because that's going
to be a lot more work to get that done
so you would like to see the language
that says a substantial change or
addition means a greater than onethird
increase in capacity footprint or height
of an existing energy facility and and
and possibly add that we
discussed one at increase in capacity
not to exceed 100 megawatt okay not have
that in there okay I I'm I would be good
with leaving that language in but we
have to take the following paragraph
which design tries to Define this F Fast
Track process we have to take that out I
mean there's just no way we can yeah two
yeah just put that in put that in the
waters future Bill yes yeah
yes
all right all right so that's a plan a
question on that the end of that uh
section uh which is two and
three get a question from back there why
you address them first Mr shulock please
come
up just trying to work my way through
the language with examples to see how
you might want it to work um and so a
substantial change means a change in the
energy
source okay and so if you're changing
the energy source then you would get the
fast track under two if you leave that
there or whatever benefit you get from
just making a substantial change under
the current rules right um but if you
make a greater than 1ir increase in the
footprint
right you get the fast trck don't you
really want that to be if it's the Le if
if you're doing something less than
onethird of the footprint then you get
the fast track or whatever benefit you
currently get right I think that's the
way it's written isn't it a substantial
change means an increase of more than
the third so if it's less than a third
it's not a substantial change and if
it's not a substantial change under the
existing rules of law you already get
the fast track okay but under two you
get the fast track if it's a substantial
change oh I see what you're saying if we
eliminate two then there's no mechanism
for any fast track so we need to leave
two
in well I'm just not sure you want to
get a fast track if somebody quadruples
the size right right it would only be if
it's less than a third no but it says
greater than a
third
see up up in yeah colon five it says
greater than a third so that makes it a
substantial change and a substantial
change doesn't get the fast track no
under two substantial change does get
the fast track 180 days
okay that's why I was oh okay that's why
I was suggesting we leave this whole
issue until later needs some work
because I think it needs more work I I
don't think that for the purposes of the
amendment we're trying to create for HB
609 that we can do justice to everything
that needs to happen to make this
definition and what happens after the
definition is
made uh as rigorous as it needs to be
and that's what Senator Waters Bill
presumably will allow us to do so that's
why I think we should just drop this
change Al together yeah I have to agree
with you it's getting getting overly
complicated to try to get this thing
through and uh in reality to my
knowledge it's only be been a real major
issue uh on the scrubber at meramac
where we battled for a long time over
what a substantial change was it wasn't
but I don't think it's come up all that
often that waiting another year will
really hurt too
much representative I don't disagree but
I I get the feeling that attorney
shulock is trying to help us be
consistent with ourselves because if
we're going to pass the first section as
part of this bill we may be inconsistent
if we don't have something to modify it
as currently is it may not be the
correct thing in section two but if we
don't pass them at the same time and we
don't know if the other bill is going to
pass it may create some problems within
the statute in terms of clarity yeah so
what I'm advocating is that we don't
change number
one well I'm talking about number two
going with number number one something
needs to be there I think well we don't
change number one number two is is um a
proposal a new proposal so that won't go
forward either I'm saying we're not
going to touch this existing part of
Statute at all so we're going to leave
out the substantial redefinition we're
gonna have to push that out well then
there's no inconsistency yeah thank you
for recognizing me okay thank you so
you're suggesting that we leave section
H5 as it is is in current statute yes
for now
yes all right so the next section then
would be application for a
certificate excuse me Mr chairman I'm
just yes go ahead at the top of that
page and I'm trying to figure out where
this popped in uh it's it's not in red
but it says notwithstanding the
foregoing an applicant May request the
site evaluation committee to assume
jurisdiction etc etc
I'm not seeing that in the existing
statute is that am I just looking in the
wrong place where does this all of a
sudden pop in because this is
this section two RSA uh where it starts
with RSA 162 H7 notwithstanding that's
all new language right but on the top of
page
four it's it continues on from page
three there's a section there and in
section three which is on the bottom of
page three it says it's just line
through uh and then it goes over to the
top of the P next page and it says not
withstanding the foregoing an applicant
May request and I'm just wondering where
that came from because I don't see it in
that that's in current
statute okay it's in current Statute in
what section uh section H5 item three
H5 I don't even have an H5 item three in
M well in in the current statute not
yeah that's what I'm looking at H5 I see
H I don't
know the RSA that's online may not be up
to date okay it mustn't be okay yeah I'm
looking at the RSA that's online right
now yeah okay I'm looking at the one
online now and it doesn't show any H3
and it's H5 shows H five but no section
two or three no section three says the
the applications shall be governed by
the applicable laws rules and
regulations of the agencies and shall be
subject to the provisions of RSA 162
2-f or RSA 162-h in effect on the date
of filing notwithstanding the foregoing
and applicant May request the site
evaluation committee to assume
jurisdiction okay and in the event that
the site evaluation committee agrees to
assert jurisdiction the facility shall
be subject to the provisions of this
chapter five okay because I looked it up
online and it's not there so I what I've
observed is
that sometimes you don't see see the
correct information in an RSA online and
that's because your computer if you've
visited that RSA before your computer
caches right the information that was
there and it doesn't
reload uh properly to update the online
so I would flush my cash if I were you
and you can show me how to flush my cash
then later okay okay later we'll talk
about that the only cash I know how to
flush is what I'm getting rid of money
for something have you experienced that
representative
Corman uh well I've certainly
experienced web pages being out of date
not not specifically our our rsas
however okay thank you right all right
so let's move now to the changes to the
next section which is
H7 application for a
certificate so this section just make
some changes
to the fact that the chairperson will
now be the person who determines whether
a application is administratively
complete and if it's not
administratively
complete what to do next
um just a little confused the question
the chair the committee chairperson or
designated presiding officer is there a
provision for something like that
somewhere else this is the first time I
think I've seen that term designated
providing officer well remember when we
discussed section five under H3 the
senior serving attorney member of the Pu
Shall Serve as chairperson and some of
the some of the uh duties underneath
that a allow him to delegate that
responsibility if we take that out which
we offer okay which we decided we're
going to do then the some of these
changes no longer probably um make sense
off that's okay that's where that came
from
anyway so does what I'll have uh Mr Gs
do is go through this language
again in light of the deletion of
section five in H3 to see if any of this
language needs to stay or if it can
disappear and if and if it
disappears
then we won't have any real changes to
make to this
section go ahead representative thank
you um so I noted uh this is the first
of three
places three places
three places where um the existing
RSA was changed by hb281 which is
currently in chaptered law uh the
language here in the amendment has the
the RSA before the changes from
281 so it needs to actually be updated
to be in concordance with the changes
made to this particular paragraph and
I'm looking at parag uh H7 paragraph 4
that changed from
hb281 so is it already changed on our
version no so the version we have here
is is before the changes from hb281 were
Incorporated so so this particular
paragraph paragraph 4 just needs to be
brought into concordance with hb281
changes but this is correct already
updated on in the actual online version
the online version I don't think the
online version is correct let me just
take a quick look here it probably
hasn't been updated based on hb281 says
effective October 7th
2023 looks like it might be well that
would be that that would be the
effective date that would be the
effective date of 281 that's 10 days ago
so all right so maybe that is up to date
all right so I will ask Mr gets to this
language and to take into account the U
language that's in 281 yeah and and
what's online in the current RSA has not
been updated oh well it yeah but I'm
looking at the language and it hasn't
been updated okay the actual
language I have a question uh yes
representative you said we're going to
eliminate 162
h35 I thought we were talking about just
making that to be the U chair of the Pu
and then leaving all the duties that are
there corre including assigning someone
as a presiding officer okay yeah that's
what I meant by eliminate I meant
eliminate the previous directive that
the senior serving attorney of the Pu be
the
chairperson so that'll be actually it's
a rewrite it's not an
elimation
all right so it it definitely appears
we're going to have to have another
meeting we can't um move forward based
on what we have here so we're going to
have to have another meeting with a a
new
Fresh uh Amendment Draft before we can
move forward how does next Tuesday the
24th look to
everyone just
fabulous first of it's my birthday I
don't want to be here it's your birthday
yeah so I guess we'll have to have cake
then right
um H yeah me too as long as it's in the
morning I have a damn issue in Durham
meeting in the afternoon okay 10 o'clock
10:24 work for everybody yep okay I will
have a new draft made I will send it to
everybody before 10 24 and hopefully on
10:24 we will be able
to come to
a final decision on an amendment so that
I can submit it for drafting so that
it'll be ready for executive session on
November
6th that is now the date of an executive
session based
on how this subcommittee is working with
along with the other subcommittees so on
the 6th the November
6th there will be a public hearing at
9:30 on a non- gerine amendment to House
Bill
458 and then at 10 o'clock we will have
executive session on all 12 of
our
9:30 the non-gain amendment to HB
458 simply reestablishes and continues
is an assessment committee that's
currently in operation but whose
operation ceases as of I don't know
November 30th or something assessment of
what pardon assessment of what uh
utility prop generation property oh oh
the property tax yeah PAB bram's
commission all right any further uh
business to bring before the
subcommittee representative cor yeah so
I did identify other
um just bookkeeping or housekeeping
issues here um as I mentioned the
paragraph I just discussed was the first
of three places where it looked like the
um changes from hb281 had not been
incorporated into this particular
Amendment and I can refer you to the
other
two um so H7 paragraph
committe shall
decide um yeah yeah but with the
chairperson or designated presiding
officer shall decide there there were
changes uh from hb281 that were not
incorporated into this particular
language in our
Amendment and then the other place was
uh same same section paragraphs 78 and n
okay got it update to
281 no yeah I mean we should at least
check
that okay and um as I read it section uh
h21 and H22 we're part of 281 and so
don't need to be be part of this
amendment great yeah got that thank
you okay anything
additional well thank you everybody for
being here today I appreciate your input
I think we can still get to an
amendment we'll know um for sure on the
24th because if we don't get it done on
that day it doesn't get done because
there's no way we're going to get it
done by November 6th if we don't have
something in hand on the 24th so we'll
see you on the 24th and
uh let me know if you have anything
you'd like to discuss about this or any
other
issue that's it for now signing off so
long thank
you